[Music]  journal entry 196 3-4 harold winston  status update on specimen 8 by now we're  all used to our super intelligent  gorillas on the colony but the hamster  we've named him hammond continues to be  one of our biggest surprises even though  he's grown from the genetic modification  we have more trouble keeping track of  him than any of the other animals  somehow he managed to get out of his  cage again it's because days to find him  i can't help but wonder what it is he's  looking for when he gets out there  he's shown impressive problem-solving  skills and adaptability to new  situations  and he's overcome all the challenges  that have been placed in front of him I  for one can't wait to see what trouble  the little guy gets up to next  Oh  you